La computación cuántica ha entrado en la era de la utilidad
lo que significa que podemos empezar a usar computadoras cuánticas para resolver
problemas del mundo real, incluyendo algunos que son muy difíciles
para las computadoras clásicas
un tema común en la era actual
es que un problema se resuelve
por primera vez en una computadora cuántica
y luego la gente encuentra una forma de hacerlo en una clásica
este ciclo entre la computación clásica
y la cuántica, empujándose mutuamente hasta sus
límites, probablemente continuará
por algunos años; hay clases de problemas donde la computación
cuántica puede tener una ventaja demostrable
sobre la computación clásica
dado el avance en áreas como
la reducción de errores y el número de qubits disponibles
también hay áreas de aplicación enteras
donde la computación cuántica
podría ser útil en un futuro relativamente cercano
una de estas áreas es el aprendizaje automático cuántico o QML
el aprendizaje automático cuántico se refiere a
la aplicación de la computación cuántica a cualquier tipo de proceso
de aprendizaje automático; existen, por supuesto,
muchos tipos de aprendizaje automático
dos tipos de especial interés son
el aprendizaje supervisado, en el que
entrenas un algoritmo usando un conjunto de datos etiquetado
y el aprendizaje no supervisado, en el que
el algoritmo trabaja con muestras sin etiquetar
e intenta aprender sobre la distribución
o la función que la genera
un algoritmo no supervisado podría
por ejemplo aprender a generar nuevas muestras
de la misma distribución, o cómo
agrupar las muestras en grupos con características similares
tanto el aprendizaje supervisado como el no supervisado suelen implicar
la inserción de datos en espacios de mayor dimensión
y la manipulación de datos en espacios de mayor dimensión
debería hacernos pensar en la computación cuántica
déjame explicarlo: imagina intentar resolver el problema de si
clasificar un punto de datos en el plano
como círculo o como cruz, dados los datos de entrenamiento etiquetados aquí
a veces los datos se pueden separar claramente con una línea
o un plano en dimensiones bajas
como se muestra aquí, y clasificar estos puntos de datos según
los que están por encima de la línea
y los que están por debajo no debería ser
ningún problema; pero mira esta distribución
claramente no hay ninguna línea visible que separe los puntos de datos
sin embargo, para estos datos podríamos imaginar algún
mapeo de dos dimensiones a tres dimensiones
de modo que tras aplicar el mapeo, nuestros datos se vean
así, y haya claramente un plano que separe las dos
clases, que podemos usar
para clasificar; si este tratamiento parece un poco simplista
tienes razón: no podemos simplemente subir los puntos de datos que queremos
sin ninguna justificación
tiene que haber un mapeo
de la distribución en 2D que separe efectivamente
nuestros puntos de datos para que podamos
usar el mapeo para clasificar nuevos puntos de datos
esto se tratará más en la lección de repaso de
aprendizaje automático, pero basta con decir
que el problema puede verse
como probar muchos mapeos distintos en este espacio de mayor dimensión
para ver cuáles producen la mejor
separación de los puntos de datos de distintas clases
esta manipulación de datos en dimensiones superiores
es un área donde la computación cuántica
puede tener un gran impacto; para entender por qué
volvamos a las diferencias entre la computación clásica
y la cuántica: así como
las computadoras clásicas usan bits de información
las computadoras cuánticas usan qubits
pero para un número determinado de bits, digamos cuatro,
una computadora clásica puede tomar cualquiera de
dos elevado a cuatro, o dieciséis estados posibles
una computadora cuántica también puede acceder a dieciséis estados posibles
pero puede existir en una superposición de todos
los dieciséis estados simultáneamente
y las operaciones se pueden realizar sobre toda esta superposición
con cuatro qubits esto puede no parecer
tan relevante, pero imagina lo que se podría hacer con
una computadora cuántica en dos elevado a veinte o
dos elevado a ciento veintisiete
estados simultáneamente; hay muchas otras diferencias
entre la computación clásica y la cuántica que
todas jugarán un papel en esta materia
los estados cuánticos tienen amplitudes de probabilidad complejas
las manipulaciones de sistemas cuánticos se realizan con
operadores unitarios y las computadoras cuánticas están sujetas a distintos
tipos de ruido que las computadoras clásicas
estas diferencias surgirán
a lo largo de tu trabajo en aprendizaje automático cuántico en áreas
como codificación de datos, mapeo de características y mitigación de errores
en algunos casos estas diferencias entre la computación clásica
y la cuántica nos permiten diseñar
algoritmos completamente nuevos; eso fue una visión general muy breve
de la unión de dos campos enormemente complejos
pero esperemos que dos cosas queden claras
el aprendizaje automático suele resolver problemas
manipulando datos en dimensiones muy altas
y en segundo lugar, las computadoras cuánticas están bien preparadas
para manipular datos en dimensiones altas
y lo hacen de manera distinta a los sistemas clásicos
esto debería darte una idea
de por qué el aprendizaje automático es un campo prometedor
para la aplicación de la computación cuántica útil